they were right so before episode 7 and
people got to see it early at Star Wars
celebration and early reviews came out
and people calling this one the best
episodes of the Mandalorian and just
calling it generally and really great
episode and the best of season three
apparently bringing everything together
and they even to those disappointed from
the previous episodes will not be
disappointed in this world now I've read
in that category I have not liked season
3 of demand loan so far so I came into
this episode with a little sliver of
Hope hoping these people were correct
and they were this episode was
absolutely incredible definitely one of
the best of the whole show and people
call it their favorite episode I'd be
like you know what fair enough that's a
valid opinion for me it is definitely
out there but I still feel like some
people will be upset with this episode
because it sets up the sequel Trilogy
more but guys that is inevitable so what
we can hope for is that they do it in
the best way possible which I think they
are doing because honestly I had no
issues with this episode all of it was
great and oh my Lord morph Gideon's man
Lauren inspired Outfitters damn awesome
and just get in himself has just some
sort of presence for when he comes onto
screen it's just epic and you're just
taken away by every single scene he's in
his performance is immaculate and what I
really love about this episode is I
actually have no clue how din Jaron is
going to get out of this situation and
that single-handedly makes me really
excited for this episode it's a lot of
stories and movies these days are quite
predictable and stuff but honestly I do
not know how he's gonna get out of this
one I'm guessing the other man loans are
going to come and help him and stuff but
I mean like in what way are they going
to help him like are we going to see
losses are we going to see backup of
some kind like Boba Fett coming like how
are they going to do it that is the
power that I don't know and I'm very
excited for that but anyway that just
brought us to the conclusion of this
video let me know your thoughts of
episode 7 in the comment section below
and if you're new to the Channel please
consider subscribing thanks for watching
guys